last week it was a big story Starbucks
launched a campaign called race together
where they encourage their baristas to
engage their customers in conversations
about race now there was so much
criticism of the race together campaign
Starbucks has already pulled the plug
yeah and I just want to take a second
here to stop the show and say I for one
I'm very disappointed
in Starbucks for giving up on the fight
to promote racial harmony in fact I've
decided to pick up the struggle they so
quickly abandoned by urging all of us to
engage in a lively discussion on the
state of race relations in America after
all the sacrifice embodied over the
years by the civil rights movement it's
our responsibility as Americans and as
humans to pick up the torch and march on
like dr. Martin Luther King I to dream
of equality for all my black brethren
because I believe oh and its leaders
what does Kona know about civil rights
this version of struggle is taking off
his yoga pants Conan is whiter than a
tour of Orange County on a Segway
scooter Conan thinks some Alabama is a
point guard in the WNBA
Conan so white what do you meant uh sure
at the Grammys he asked him to lead him
to his seat
just listen to that bleached cow skull
when Mona told me he had an African
friend it turned out to be Oscar
Pistorius Cohen is so white he thought
that Ferguson riots were about Craig
Ferguson leaving late night is that
human Altoids still talking so in
closing as the great Maya Angelou once
said try to be a rainbow in someone's
cloud we are that rainbow
[Applause]
you